brendan schaub's a [ __ ]
chiseled fat [ __ ] yeah like he's got
the slick hair the cool shoes got a
chain on like i would never even think
to put on a chain oh he's the white part
of bacon yeah i always call him the
white part of bacon still good but damn
boy yeah yeah a little thick and not
good for you yeah he's a thick crust
and he's got the cheese in there too oh
yeah you know you stretch it it pulls
but yeah
it's like dang how much cheese i know i
know but he's like seven foot one he's
got a huge piece and a badass that's
crazy one leg dude his other that it's a
it's a [ __ ] penis with a neon
wow he's got a bendy dick yeah he's got
ligaments oh dude yeah he can stand on
his dick yeah that's pretty crazy it's a
kickstand a dick stand you know what's
amazing about brendan mann and uh
because he and i do the king and the
string podcast and
it's like
he's like to go from football right to
fighting
which you would never even imagine if
you talk to him that he was a ufc
fighter i know he's so sweet yeah
it's like he he's he's like he's kind of
like that american dream in a weird way
of like that if you work hard
um
you can get you can make things happen
you know yeah like he never stops
working right you know it's crazy he
works so hard bro it's crazy like he's
he's up in the morning he's on that bike
he's got his family he's flying to
columbus this weekend he's coming back
he's doing this podcast he's doing that
and he keeps a good attitude yes
positivity is very underrated yeah yeah
he's very positive he looks good the
whole time he's always smiling you never
see him like ah [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah
and you're right he does work and and
that and that that vibe that he has
that's one of the things that i think a
younger generation with comedy
that they attract to more because they
don't
they don't have this kind of left like
this
to them it's all like about it's more
fun yes let's have fun it doesn't matter
who we are what's going on let's have a
good time and that's what he has yeah
whereas some of the old some of the
others are we're like oh man you know
yeah yeah somebody you know some i have
these this doldrum inside of me and
that's what keeps me going not to
mention
people watch the news all day it's
nothing but shootings and death and
politics and trump and all this [ __ ]
coming at you see when you see this
fun-loving happy go-lucky guy you're
like all right it's like ah i feel a
little better like i can breathe a
little then you know because sometimes
you watch like bill burns just like dude
i [ __ ] kill you your mom's a [ __ ] and
your dad's gay and all and you're like
all right all right all right
you're like yeah i did it i did it yeah
yeah exactly don't hurt me uh you feel
like he's gonna give you a wedgie yeah
and then you see shob and you're like
all right it's like a it's like a golden
retriever oh yeah he's kind of like a
chewbacca ah yes that broke into like a
claire's boutique and will not leave
dude
no matter what bro he said we're open 24
hours a day now yeah
if a chewbacca ran through a armani
exchange and [ __ ] stuck to him yeah he's
a he's a cool dude i protected with him
today he's a good egg he is a good egg
man like i did his podcast once and this
is the complete contrast of new york i
pull in it's a sunny day he pulls in red
ferrari i see one [ __ ] giant shoe of
an air jordan hit the concrete i'm like
oh who's this tom cruise you know and
it's [ __ ] him like you're a comic
what's going on but it's a it's a
different era
yeah
yeah he's in that i don't know they just
i wish sometimes that i had like the
clothing confidence of like yeah and
then i know oh they're so sexy god i'm
just like does this fit this is never
fit that's the only thing i ever think
when i put something on yeah maybe like
we went to public school yeah i got i
have every time i'm in a dressing room
at like a gap i put something on like a
jean jacket and i go hey this looks
pretty good and all i hear is eight
friends going what the [ __ ] do you think
you're doing you think you can pull that
off you [ __ ] loser you piece of [ __ ]
or you kill yourself and i'm like all
right there we go that was a fun moment
and you put that [ __ ] right back on the
hanger
yeah dude
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one
you